you have the bed with idea of the birth
with me tonight the bat that Pistorius
used to batter down his bathroom door is
used in court to recreate the crime
scene and a forensic expert contradicts
this Tauruses account of whether he was
wearing his prosthetic legs the night of
the killings good evening from Pretoria
where the toilet door from Oscar
pistorius's house was brought into court
today to show how the athlete's battered
it down with a cricket bat
Pistorius fired four times through the
door in the early hours of Valentine's
Day last year killing his 29 year old
model girlfriend reeva Steenkamp
Pistorius has always said he thought
there was an intruder hiding behind the
door only later he says did he realize
that Steenkamp was not asleep in the
bedroom the state's forensic expert
testified that the height of the
indentations on the door suggested
Pistorius was not wearing his prosthesis
when he broke it down Pistorius says he
was Paul Harrison reports
so far the evidence brought before court
has largely been in the form of witness
testimonies but today the very toilet
door from Oscar pistorius's house and
the cricket bat he used to break it down
were brought into the courtroom
the key question had the Olympian been
wearing his prosthesis as he battered
the wooden door with the bat the night
he shot reeva Steenkamp it was Colonel
Yohan famille ins job to see if the
markings on the door did in fact match
that of Pistorius his cricket bat the
small one on the edge here is there is
the one mark and the second mark the
investigation revealed that the cricket
bat actually made a physical match with
the marks which is a which is a
undisputable confirmation that the bat
was used to do pass the door do you have
the bed with you I do have the bed with
me you just described the bedroom what
what name what's the name of the bed
it's a laser English willow na+
cricket bed on the bed on the face of
the bed what what you find thee my lady
there's a couple of of signatures I
suspect it's from well-known people I do
not know the signatures but there's a
couple of signatures on the face of it
that's about IRRI see that's the bet
that I received on the 26th of lady Mae
a big leave that the witness leave the
witness box and demonstrate support my
lady if you permit me I would like to
take off my jacket just to be easier
my lady the bed made a physical match
with a dog in this position if you stand
upright is it comfortable to hit there
the police forensic expert then aim to
show the indentations could not have
been made by Oscar Pistorius standing
wearing his prosthesis not a natural
position but matching the markings on
the bat with those on the door the
witness believed it made more sense that
Pistorius was standing on his stumps
people now my I was able to quote ask
that the shoulder height of the kernel
be measured as he'ii stay because you
might contact with me with a price break
it do for between 1.2 for 1.25 the
prosecution then turned to the moment in
the bathroom that Oscar Pistorius used
his cricket bat to prise off one of the
toilet door panels seen here already
removed in this exclusive photograph
obtained by Sky News taken shortly after
the shooting can we deal with the second
the Bedouin through the went through the
door and he's actually marks on the toe
of the bed which corresponds with with
what happened with what happened yet the
bat went through the door and these
marks were created win-win the person
kind of twisted the bed to break open to
break open the panel this the shape yeah
actually found the exact physical match
with with the face of the bed and the
dead angle the marks on the side of the
bed that is the second characteristic
that might me to believe that the bat
was in this was in this position when it
went through the door that's angle of
attack
that's correct model they you're not
standing upright
no I squatted down to actually get my
hands in the natural position holding
the handle of the bed in the angle at
the physical
evidence on the bed indicated to me and
as if to emphasize the point Harry now
then asked Colonel Foreman to show the
court how he believed Oscar Pistorius
had hit the second point
at that time when you did the
investigation did you know what the
shoulder height of the kiss would be
without this procedure sorry my lady I
knew that they would be considerably
shorter than and what he would be with
his prosthesis but I was not privy to
the information on measurements done on
mr. Pistorius at the time that I that I
did the investigation despite these
graphic demonstrations pointing to Oscar
Pistorius hitting the door while not
wearing his prosthesis the athletes
legal team continued to express some
confusion as to the prosecution's
position on the matter that's not the
state's case we have further particulars
and the state's cases that it was on his
prosthesis it's not my case that he was
on his prosthesis that was bad something
had happened to the bail application
but as I'm standing here today and the
evidence of Captain Magana would be that
he was not on his prosthesis and I did
not say that it was Oscar Pistorius
argues his legal team must have been
wearing his prosthesis as balance would
have been an issue they put Colonel
forum Elin through an impromptu test to
demonstrate I know you're going to be
lower now because you're not standing
with your knees on the little bench but
just for present person on the carpet on
your knees like you would hit the door
as you demonstrate it would you now do
me a favor and lift your feet because
mr. stand up on your knees but lift your
feet up I can't see what's happening
just explain to notation are you losing
your balance
you can try the guy in case you think
this trick enough oh but I didn't
teleport what happened to you my lady
when I left my feet I'm off balance mr.
Pistorius of died was trying and we'll
get to that at the later point to show
it is fine to illustrate someone
standing on his knees but with support
by his feet and what I want to put to
you he has even less support than your
knees we'll get to that and expert
evidence of that Colonel formalin was
then employed to take another test the
aim this time to show that the cricket
bat could in fact be matched to marks on
the door if Pistorius had been wearing
his prosthesis standing position you can
think you're back in this is it
unnatural to bend your back when you hit
something this is a very uncomfortable
position you don't have to paint your
legs just your back and go feel like
you've done it before
yes does it match
am I correct and understanding that all
the marks will match also standing the
only differences you say that it was an
unnatural position in for you to be into
it the door
before the court adjourned for lunch a
burning question from Barry Roux if it
was the witness's belief Oscar Pistorius
had been standing on his stumps why had
he not put it in his report you gave
four important what is not in the report
is that the accused master or was on his
stumps when he heated door with the
cricket bat that's not in your report
m'lady as I said earlier my evidence in
chief was that by the time that I did
the investigation on the door Ally
request to me was to determine if there
were any marks on the door that related
to the cricket bat that's not what it's
all about we know one thing Hugh are you
at the forensics Department when you
have additional information in your f
report you bring out a second report
myleik as I said in my evidence in chief
during the consultation I think it was
in November the first consultation with
mr. mr. Nell regarding my report I just
mentioned it to him as a side note that
my observation is that mr. Pistorius was
not on his legs he was on his on his
stumps I mean the door was he not
knowing that it was an issue coming up
Pistorius defense lawyer Barry root
takes on the state expert and alleges
the door has been altered whilst it was
in police storage
welcome back to Pretoria and the
continuing trial of Oscar Pistorius for
the murder of his girlfriend well we've
already seen the police forensic expert
colonel gamelon is such an important
witness for both the prosecution and the
defense it wasn't unexpected that his
testimony continued for the rest of the
day Barry Roo was surprised to find out
that other pieces of wood from the crime
scene
had not been examined by the police
forensic expert what you see on that
photo
my lady on this photo I see the door I
see that Marcus on the door the cricket
bat the angle I suspected to be there's
some some pieces of wood next to that I
see it now yes my lady
no I didn't happen I was at the scene I
didn't pay attention to that and I
actually didn't see it I must have never
looked at my lady it's right next to the
door you will agree by just looking at
the photo it's not difficult to see it
well now it's probably it's obvious if
you know it see but Roo wasn't finished
undermining Canova Merlin's account this
time an unexplained dent on the door was
the focus of attention you see a mark
you see where the handle is and when you
go down there's a distinct mark yes you
pointed to that distinct law my lady I
did indeed look at that mark but I could
not find anything that convinced me that
that mark was due to the due to the
cricket bat on behalf of stories we will
present evidence that that mark it's
caused by the prosthesis kicking that
door making contact with that door
and the fabric of the sock was in fact
still in bed and found and varnish of
the door on the prosthesis in his
version of the events in trying to pick
up my steam come you could have stumbled
over it so that's just another version I
don't say you didn't kick it but what
I'm saying is that it's the kicking is
not the only only sort of possible
source of that will you go and take a
plank and stumble over it and bring it
back and come back in the evidence and
show me a mark that can replicate will
you do it often
what and we can do another control
services because I tell you Kenneth
far as I'm concerned as far as I know
where anyone requested to to do analysis
to link the
the prosthetic legs with kicking down of
the door I'm trying to understand the
police and investigation
you see marks on a door with someone not
be asked from the forensics department
to look at those marks and try and find
if they can be given any explanation
front in the bail application I put on
my prosthetic legs ran back to the
bathroom and tried to kick the toilet
door open so it's not that the police
was unaware of this version you see this
something you think well we can look at
it it's not too light
we don't need months and months and
weeks and weeks let us go back to the
door and it's chicken maybe we can
assist the accused and find something
that would corroborate this version
obviously 40c approach rather well I've
done my investigation and that's it I'm
not gonna I'm not going to bother with
with the version that will be presented
in court and then we can the court can
decide on usual words I'm not going to
bother with easy because it would not it
would not change my my investigation
that I did shoeprints
police shoe prints I saw somewhere at a
port it's consistent with the Felicia's
that looks like it's like a police ship
and how did that come about I don't know
I get you see the shoe prints no I did
not see how there was fine marks on the
on the door and top of one stage but not
as clear as as these ones so how did
they disappear I don't know I must admit
the door and the bed was not exactly in
the same condition as it was collected
because it was already handled by
several people
ported whatever and and footprints again
is just another foot prints as well no
no of course someone wiping it off not
appreciating police good footprints on
the door that's what it must be not so
that's possible I'm not sure that you
can see from that distance I can see
through thank you very you see them I
see them please show them to me on this
plank they not on this plank my lady but
they take quite drastic law so to speak
it's quite significant right there
that's quite significant yes my lady
where they there when you saw the Doris
able to help to assemble name on this
photograph it doesn't seem like those
marks are present on the door whilst the
door was in the safekeeping of the
forensic Department it somehow happened
to get serious Marc sermon which did not
exist on the 8th of March 2000 from this
it appears like it that something
happened to the door well with me to
discuss the day's courtroom testimony as
JC de Klerk a forensic ballistics
specialist who's been involved in many
post mortems and our own crime
correspondent Martin brunt Martin what
did you make of today I mean this
afternoon the defense absolutely
shredded the prosecution case it seemed
yeah Colonel vermeuhlen I was beginning
to feel very sorry for Colonel Clouseau
some of us were calling him because time
and time again
berry roofing the defense was exposing
shortcomings and very basic shortcomings
in him in his investigation there were
missing pieces of the door said very
well mr. and the colonel said yes I knew
that but I was told that that they
couldn't be found and then he was shown
a photograph that showed the door with
those pieces of wood and the colonel
then having to admit that he'd actually
used that photograph in compiling his
report and he hadn't asked his
colleagues for an inventory of all the
other things that had been collected
from the crime scene so he became more
uncomfortable as the day went on and
Barry Roux was in his element I mean
we've seen the Rottweiler lawyer up
until now that I guess this was his most
successful day in making the police
investigation looks shoddy
at the very best now do you think it
compares with a British investigation or
is that just not fair well you know we
always think that British police at best
don't we in Scotland Yard is this beacon
of excellence
I think they Scotland Yard officers
would be the first to admit that they
don't always get things right
it was great drama though I mean if you
ever you've covered court cases for
years and years decades have you ever
had had a it's a recreation of the crime
scene quite like this well you get
little recreate recreations but I mean
it was a day of spectacular evidence I
mean literally I can't remember a toilet
door being brought into court before and
somebody being asked to hit it with a
cricket bat so that was that was a big
entertainment value and at the end of
the day me this was all about and was
Oscar Pistorius on his false legs or
wasn't
and it doesn't really matter except that
if the prosecution can prove that their
case is right it shows that he was lying
and if he was lying about whether he was
on his stumps or his false legs he could
be shown to be lying about other things
JC you've not only got a specialty in
ballistics and been involved in
post-mortems but you've also being a
member of the South African Police
Service for many years how embarrassing
was this day for you was quite
embarrassing for the evidence to
actually show up in court that this
extra imminence or extra marks on the
door that came out now all of a sudden
that wasn't on the initial investigation
and the integral that you need to ask
you question is does that marks change
the result of Konoe formula and at the
end of the day it's not going to change
what Cano from Yemen found yes there
might be some other evidence that like
blood spatter maybe that was on the door
but color for me and I didn't examine it
he was asked to examine the cricket bat
to the door now it's not in dispute that
the cricket bat was used if it wasn't
dispute they would have been far over
off showing striation whose only cricket
bat matching the kickin back to exactly
the door but that's not the case here
they found that the ticket met was use
we all know that I don't know how the
evidence of the missing parts is going
to play it and really a big road the
fence is saying it's a crucial bit of
evidence because those splinters meant
and the absence of the splinters meant
he couldn't reconstruct the the door
accurately therefore he might have miss
marks I don't I don't agree with that
if you're gonna look at the door that
the biggest part of the doorway the
bullets went through the big mark of the
bat is still there that little splinters
yes you can put everything back together
but then it's going to take them a year
now if you take all little splinters and
try and match everything up what is it
gonna prove how did you feel about him
being asked to kneel and recreate it all
again he I think he felt very
uncomfortable I think it's a bit unfair
if you take Oscar since he's been small
he had no legs so he runs on his legs
he's used to that is the unstable yes
maybe is maybe it's not as strong but to
ask somebody an eyeball body to stand
your knees anybody can try it and I can
tell you you will definitely fall over
because you
lack of balance that Oscars evenly
contamination with that footprint that
very rules the looting was a police
footprint on top of the panel of the
door ie they walked over the evidence
when they were collecting it is not good
no it's not good it means that the crime
scene was tainted in other words if
other evidence that could have helped us
could have gone lost could have been
changed the cartridges could have been
changed you know there's so much other
things that can happen around the
evidence for the shoe but they say that
it's a pollution but they need to find
the right shoe put it in and say it is
appreciate it can be somebody else's JC
de Klerk the suits expert thank you very
much Martin broke Crone curse but I'm
sure there's going to be more drama as
we carry on the Pistorius trial is on
Sky News from 7:30 every weekday morning
and there's a special program at 9:30 in
the evening to join us